alors là on n'est pas bien du tout du
coup j'ai pas trop pris mon temps pour
réfléchir
c'était plus occupés à redémarrer le
programme mais bon c'est c'est un bug
informatique malheureusement c'est un
mélange de connexion et du et du serveur
switch qui a du mal à le redémarrer
après mais du coup du coup je fais de
mon mieux je fais de mon mieux mais
c'est pas toujours évident alors puis
envie de tenter qu'ils étaient 4 ici ça
marche pas du tout en fait
[Musique]
aucun cas fievet 14 qui fait
on va voir comment il réagit
surtout ces deux échecs roi des huns qui
on prend tour c'est un peut-être je vais
tenter calicéo échec intermédiaire est
prise là quand même et surtour c'est un
bien envie de ce retour prend 1 2 il va
prendre ici je vais prendre prendre et
j'aurais rien j'ai bien envie de revenir
vers b4 venir en d3 et on s'y prend je
prends il vient là je reviens en d6 ça
mais il va faire froid ici ok du coup on
a fait retour des 8
il va faire fou d'être en affaires
privées 4 mai va faire flouer 4 on va
être complètement perdre bon de toute
façon c'était écrit d'avancé on va
balancer le pion façon il va prendre en
b cette affaire tourbe et 8 et b4 c'est
un peu notre seule chance
non ok dupouy ferment le jeu ça c'était
sûr on va faire des trois pour essayer
de faire foulée quatre échecs bon c'est
mon méga utile et j'ai envie de faire 5
en premier non on va faire [ __ ] des
quatre à commencer par 5 comme ça on
pourra faire peut-être fou et six fours
bekkat échec je sais pas c'est des idées
comme ça qui me viennent appuyer presque
plus de temps
j'ai passé un échec ici
vous pouvez ramène le roi j'ai envie de
lui prendre le bureau il prend ça ici
avec ce que prendre le sein qu'après et
se simplifier la vie
bien joué très bien joué mais vous
connaissez partie était difficile avec
le redémarrage de tous leurs de tout le
truc c'était pas évident on va
abandonner pas repartir sur une partie
qu'on peut jouer depuis le début alors
que 4 c 5
allez on va faire qu'il y avait trois
pour le moment allez c'est exactement ce
que je voulais faire un grand vide ils
elles sont une très bonne ouverture mais
qui permet d'avoir une position jouable
sans trop de théorie donc ça on peut
obtenir cette position en partant d'une
française aussi plus ou moins du coup à
trois faut s'en prendre aux pions b4
pour réussir à installer une chaîne de
pions ok je fais juste faire food et 3
il peut même prendre sur échec juste
croquer en fait
alors ok sur l'échec mais elles n'ont
juste faire ces trois mains du coup il
ya deux bons il va prendre juste faire
caïds et deux n'ont pas se fatiguer et
puis à convaincre
et puis on craque puis le pion à trois
on le récupérera plus tard on aura un
bel avantage de développement hockey b3
échec
ok sur food et de il veut peut-être
faire b2 et encore mais j'ai envie de
jouer ces trois en fait super
pragmatique
du coup son pion bva peut-être tombé et
je suis très très content de protéger
mon centre comme ça en fait je suis
content de cette structure de pions au
centre en fait
du coup comme a du coup je vais
débarrasser de mon mauvais fou et je
veux me débarrasser de son pion aussi en
b3 qui aurait pu être pénible à long
terme
ok on va faire petit rock j'ai pas peur
d'avoir le la tour en face du roi je
suis très heureux de roque et en fait ça
me fait encore un coût de développement
est bon faire à quatre comme ça on veut
essayer de sortir via vie à trois baies
bref tout allait vers des six n'a
heureusement comme on a pu le fou de
cases noires pardon c'est plus difficile
mais on pas grave dit oui m'empêche de
le faire
je vais faire c'est 4g cif et puis on
prend je fais reprise mais peut-être a
les mains sales et verbe est ici c'est
s'y prend pas ok mais ça j'avais pas vu
puisque je peux pas prendre des cinq
gymnases des six il doit prendre du
pillon bon il se réactive un peu là j'ai
un peu fait n'importe quoi j'ai un peu
fait n'importe quoi
j'ai fais vraiment n'importe quoi en
apprenant p 7
c'est un pan de pion à 6 du coup dans la
foulée on s'y fait tour à cette affaire
d'âme b26 fait autour des 8 ont fait
dame prend à 6 on va rentrer dans des
multitudes des changes en espérant que
ce soit en notre faveur
j'en sais rien d'ailleurs marrant parce
qu'il faut avoir dame prend au f5 et fo
prend comme ça sinon certaines lenteurs
qui on va revenir en b2 du coup je
protège mon pions et jeu peut-être pas
ton cas va lancer deux voire même kamel
b 5 peut-être une menace un puisque sur
puis on prend qui comprend espèce de
double triple attaque de partout bon
peut-être pas abuser non plus même si ça
me titille largement de le jouer as un
petit titre franchement qu un truc qui
me titille trop c'est du blitz et
internet on peut se faire plein ok
c'était prévu du coup je voulais ramener
madame vers une meilleure casse-tête ces
deux du coup ci prend j'ai toujours
cette espèce de double attaque bizarre
même découvert raté ce coup là on essaie
de faire dame c7 et avoir un peu de
chance un véhicule science 4 reprend b5
et ont trouvé ça un peu à faire dame
prend ici font f5 puis on prend b5 et
franges et 4 la folie pure
j'ai tout prend des singles apprend des
seize fois f5
ok ça aurait été beau
je comprends c'est ce qu'il fait
je ne comprends pas son coup moi je vais
faire à cinq je comprends pas non plus
non plus je comprends toujours pas son
coup
mince mince je ne comprends rien
comprendre ce qui se passe j'ai fait
n'importe quoi
je me suis mis tout seul en perez en
calculant des trucs de malade
au lieu de jouer simple bah ça ça perd
tout de suite mais vu j'ai rien trouvé
mais il doit y avoir quelque chose c'est
sûr c'est sûr qu'il devait voir quelque
chose n'importe quoi mais bon j'ai déjà
envie de me marrer du coup j'ai cherché
ventes les plus drôles les plus stupides
allez on essaie de jouer vite
tout ce qui nous reste mais on a fait le
beau jeu ils risquent plus tant de temps
que ça ici je vais servir à quelque
chose
cela ici alors on va le sortir par là on
va faire un échec sert à rien de faire
échec ici à ya rien je vais faire tout
recettes directes mais je n'avais pas vu
ok maintenant il va faire ça ça ça et
maintenant je suis fini je suis fait
camara quoique j'essaye encore de lutter
surtout fait autant en fait n'a utilisé
trop de temps parce que c'est tiens je
suis pas sûr qu'il aurait gagne je suis
pas du tout sûr qu'on est en jeu un peu
plus vite il aurait pas eu lauriers bon
ok on va leur jouer
allez on va tenter autre chose ma main
je voulais faire une ruine je voulais
faire une ruine dommage toujours un truc
que je connais pas du tout alors qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire de marans vraiment
faire va être obligé une structure qui
ont envie de jouer en fait je fais
n'importe quoi
je ferais n'importe quoi
aujourd'hui je fais absolument n'importe
quoi un peu déconcentré par ces
problèmes techniques et la maintenance
c'est vraiment de la merde
donc on va tenter ça je pense pas que ça
marche du tout
peut-être le beau jeu
c'est vraiment de défendre mes trucs
mais c'est tellement difficile à toute
théorique ce que je n'en sais rien j'ai
quand même l'impression que je vais
perdre du matos mais bon ok
je vais matour ans et 8 ans et puis on
verra bien après songé plus le choix
maintenant faire partie pour partie à
face on était obligé de rentrer là
dedans
ok maintenant un vieux prend avec le
pion
loin d'être réjouissant ce truc je peux
pas reprendre
aïe aïe aïe des difficultés
cherche un truc s'en sortir mais je ne
trouve rien
sans vraiment se concentrer vers la
prochaine parce que là ça devient un peu
n'importe quoi
le mieux c'est de faire food & i 6
dans ses rangs mauvais pour le mans
bref huit ans que faire
s'en prend à mon fou
je vais le garder par ici m'en fous je
la met ici
jamais le donne et se fout jamais il
enverra il le verra suis là je n'ai pas
toujours là
vous les équilibristes quand même
essayer d'aller menacer là bas la
première rangée mon footing roi je
n'arrive pas salah dans la vie nouvelle
fois pour le temps parce que sinon je
pensais qu'on devait abandonner et
finalement on a tenu encore quand même
quelques coups de mou b3 très pénible ok
ça met une petite chance sinon j'avais
peur qu'ils viennent menacer match mais
ok à main sur un stade à vos passages
doit abandonner alors c'est pas mal
sorti dans un premier temps par les faux
faux faux revenir au score l'abscons en
train de perdre contre à voir qui est
qui croient qu'ils jouent mieux que nous
ajoute il joue mieux que nous a pour le
moment mais
tenter parfois f5 peut-être n'ont-ils a
vu le piège
puis utt de reprendre ces cinq au
passage au québec comme ça pourquoi pas
la rigueur
allez hop on va sortir le cavale fait
rage 3 va donner une case of ou saas est
content bien fait mettre le fou en
sciant kétou parti veut faire ainsi
c'est pas grave
allez maintenant il est temps de dégager
sa structure de pions allez hop on
ramène des pions vers le centre recul le
fou fou très bien placés qu'il signait
en face de madame jamais très agréable
notamment à trois comme ça on va
profiter et on va mettre cette tour en
moi m 7 tours en c1 on va libérer la
case est simple fait fin pour le fou
malheureusement pour nous on va être
obligé de prendre comme ça les aide de
fonds et deux qui restent en prison là
là il faut se réveiller la porte ou quoi
comment tu peux rater des tactiques
aussi basique mais heureusement turquie
les prends des cats étaient tous reprend
qu'ils allaient prendre 2 3h de
l'épreuve et deux intermédiaires et si
je fais cavaliers prend ici c'est quoi
le truc fou prend toi français 8 hayat
en france et intermédiaires d'anglais
perdant mais dans les ventes que jusqu'à
de plus grave catastrophe
alors est ce que c'est si grave bon ce
peuvent être si grave que ça de toute
façon
j'ai envie de prendre à faire un échec
la espérait avoir un bon coup j'ai envie
de faire flouer cinq échecs et s'il fait
cavalier prend faire dana fuite allaient
le maté en force est si féroce cette
tour âge suite maths je pense c'est une
grosse faute hors froid ici parce que
maintenant s'il peut faire ça tu verras
sauvetage
je pensais que c'était gagné damman de
la chose en retour c'est parce qu'il
n'avait pas vu mais bon peut-être que
c'est pas assez de chansons ce qui est
vraiment pas vu cette tactique se
référant à 7 sur un échec et un truc que
j'ai pas vu mais je pense pas pas du
tout content c'est un trés mécontant
trimestre content de cette tactique raté
au kg 5
je tiens ici à vous honte est beaucoup
mieux placé ainsi qu'un recrutement fou
prendre ça à néma d'amendés 6 par
exemple qui à bonne température pour une
bonne partie d'échec at il une dent je
ne sais pas du tout je commençais 7
peut-être éventuellement tentés d espèce
de perpète
c'est exactement ce à quoi je pensais
il joue exactement ce à quoi je pensais
qu'est ce qu'on va faire 6 mai où là
j'ai plus de temps une nouvelle fois
j'ai envie de garder les dames en fait
parce que genre menace tout reprend 17
car il ya eu 5 et de reprendre angers 4
ce qui est une belle menace en fait tout
en clouant le truc j'ai une espèce de
plusieurs menaces auxquelles ici à tout
parent et que les cavaliers la sq avec
truc c'est que suivant ou par saddam
on va faire tout reprend 17
pour l'ons le fouet tous et est
maintenant f3 et le fou est toujours
floue et et au prochain va pouvoir l'anc
et c'est donc et menace la tour ça c'est
une menace pour commencer à ramasser les
pions et on veut faire pour prendre ce
sens qu'au prochain et on va faire je
sais pas moi on va faire tourner six
échecs n'ont pas tour des incas
l'horreur ouais j'étais plus concentré
tellement c'est gagnant j'ai juste
arrêté de réfléchir très très idiot non
mais ok mais ça c'est que des partis
c'est vraiment subite pour la peine je
me suis mis à me dire que c'était fini
c'était facile j'ai arrêté de réfléchir
alors vraiment subi à il a fait patte
hallucinant et le mec est pas content
parce que je continue à jouer simple
quand il jouait un truc complètement
perdus avec une cour de moins mais
partie vraiment stupide juste arrêter de
nous concentrer
c'était vraiment complètement gagnant
d'ailleurs je n'aime pas qu'on me la
fait pas atteint c'était tellement
facile aussi
mais à qui il aurait probablement dû
abandonner plutôt pensé partir il a tout
à fait le droit de pas abandonner armée
de la part de paris match parce qu'après
il se prend un pat faut peut-être quand
même pas abuser
alors celui ci ne joue pas cet
adversaire là a signifié par jouer voir
ce que ça donne
il a perdu sa connexion sarthe ya une
mauvaise connexion a donc on va pas
faire trop de partis vers sa connexion
et la retrouve
il a repéré la retrouve
alors point fr une scandinaves comme ça
on va essayer de rapidement se dépêtrer
de cet adversaire
oui pu faire mieux qu'un grand roque
allez ça va être marrant au moins ça va
être le beau jeu allez vous le pion aux
farnham ces singes le bien qu'il a eu
avec son fonds dont jean b3 dû
comprendre ici on sera les monstres
allait prendre du matos en force
maintenant j'arrive pas à calculer alors
tant pis faut prendre ces trois lignes
sur vous prend soin sur camaïeu 4 up
l'idée c'était de faire ça mais je suis
pas sûr qu'il ait pu faire dans le camp
des cats en premier bon allez hop
alors maintenant cette histoire là c'est
pas encore si simple que ça alors on va
échanger les tours en fait comme ça ira
plus de double attaque
parce que s'il ya moins de tours il y
aura plus de matches du couloir et la
dame pourra plus jouer
du coup ça va plutôt m'avantager bas
mais lorsqu'il fait beau jeu mais
l'hymne qui va prendre un don qui l'a
abandonné tant mieux
alors on retombe dessus alors alerté 4
parce que j'ai dû faire une ruse d'après
son envie de le ruiner
non mais là vraiment une mauvaise
connexion n'a pas de bol de retomber sur
lui
malheureusement il est vraiment il est
vraiment lent enfin la ta connexion est
vraiment lente
je suis un coup monté fois noir site où
tout se passe bien d'arrêter la partie
mais tant mieux quelque part allez on
joue contre cet adversaire alors une
carte locarn tout prix ce prise ok je
cette variante 1 du coup je vous
contrôler plus isolé à 6 bon ça me donne
envie de m'accrocher aux pions cette
histoire-là 6 jamais vu quelqu'un jouer
comme ça sa première fois déjouer cette
position des milliers de fois cette
première fois qu'un adversaire me répond
ça très étrange un puits ce qui me
laisse
mais se protéger les pions gens me faire
flamber cinq échecs peut-être fou 17
je suis pas sûr que cette intelligence
que de foot par cinq échecs dans quel
dessein brise s'est fait repousser si ce
n'était juste fait refouler 7
du coup je suis dans mon idée parce que
en fait mon idée c'était de faire
cailler b5 ici et il a un peu tous qui
est cloué ans ma foi cette dame b si ce
qui sauve encore ok mais là c'est juste
du matériel tonton râle beau jeu ce
serait faire dam des trois pour tenter
de maths mais ok ça aurait aidé le beau
jeu mais avait juste puis on prend alors
on le contrat d'un durée 9 dangerously
ch qui s'est même bizarre ça je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas un système de londres
j'ai envie de dire on va faire le
classique années de cavale en f3
solidifier tout ça on va les mater a les
droits à l'ancienne at on seulement le
choix alors sur quel âge semble
s'écouler déjà fou price est alors on va
aller mater commandes comme en maths ici
bon moi je dis on mate dans l'esprit un
g4 book g4 et g5 1
alors il est dans un esprit - taquin que
d'autres on a quand même envoyé un pion
de change est simple c'est quand même
très taquin on va voir comment ça
continuera comme ça continue les
cavaliers ici une défend tout boum h4
sarah aime réfléchir plus les pions h 5
h 6 mai où s'écoule à balancer deux
pions d'espèces d'éclaireurs c'est
logique c'est par ces logiques boom les
plus rares qu'ils avancent
je déteste ça alors attendez on va les
mettre le pion à j-6 est comme ça sur g6
on va les faire caler prend 1,4 et comme
ça on aura la case et fils qui sera
libre pour le cavalier bleu va être
obligé de prendre le cadre prendre mais
là les cases noires autour de son roi
c'est clair que c'est pas joyeux a
dangerous fiche est il si dangereux que
ça ou n'est-ce qu'un mythe
on voit là dans le jeu russe fiche j'ai
très envie de te faire une découverte
j'en ai plusieurs voilà que je découvre
comme ça on encaisse un pion au passage
on met un petit échec en étant deuxième
et on va en mettre un troisième
boumediene jour où ce fish bout des
pions j'ai acheté tarifs dessus des
cages et car j'étais pas d'heureux pas
du tout dangereux parce que ça va partir
ou pas trop crier victoire
là ça donne très envie du baron c'est
quand même g5 des deuxièmes coups ou g5
dans tag
bouh bouh
pareil fait boum quand même ça faisait
bien battu et j'ai envie de continuer
dans l'esprit bout
tu prends pas le pion aux carmes et
utérus est bénie et et psion qui sont
arrivés comme ça est parti en
escarmouche ouais on y va mais qui sont
partis loin devant partir on allait voir
ce qui se passe se sont échappés et non
pas du tout est attendue le peloton de
le peloton des autres non non nous on y
va les mecs sont des fourmis dans les 1
dans les jambes pardon on va faire à 6b
ça un boom fait une erreur complètement
si c'est pas sur l'échiquier absolument
rien à faire de ce qui fait un truc qui
me fait un peu peur me qui on va pas le
dire enfin je perde face tu en prends
pions point que f4 mais ok on va faire
ça n'existe pas farc ep 6 4 4 on va les
surveiller tout prendre bout le pion b5
quand même auquel a dû profiter et b6
puisque c'était pas un peu idiot là ce
que j'aime faire
j'ai peut-être un truc bizarre je vais
te faire e 5 qui paraît très très
mauvais à première vue mais en fait
l'idée c'est que je vais pouvoir faire
crisser 4 parce qu'il a que la case de
ou détroit pour son cavalier
du coup à première vue ça va être
complètement débile non vraiment
complètement
mais un deuxième but
ça permet faire peut-être faire
caillasser cas du coup après la dame va
devoir voilà la dame va devoir se barrer
va pouvoir reprendre en bessin qu
éventuellement après poussé hockey dont
il revient avec son cheval qu'on va lui
prendre une fois en trois et on va
pousser b4 donc fo v5 c'est pas grave on
va ignorer on va se déplacer avec le roi
du coup je suis peut-être très content
qu'ils aient foulé cinq échecs en fait
pour lombez 3 ça marche pas parce qu'ils
couvrent encore avec la dame ok je
pousse h4
vous allez viens là je vais prendre
j'aurais pris un temps fou c'est fsaa
boom tous les pions qui t'arrive dessus
ça je vais essayé d'activer mon fou
hockey et maintenant f4
ok ça c'était prévu cavaliers g6 et du
coup je vais tenir mon pions je veux
être le rend incertain comme ruiz ont
fait pas l'europe conventionnel pas de
coups conventionnés les échecs rock
beaucoup trop conventionnel pour nous
qu'elle relève mauroy du coup je me
renaud centre beaucoup mieux placé
système d'anti jeu au centre est tout l
après fois-çi ce boom des gages à faire
froid justice à venir s'en prend l'avion
qui le défend pour le moment
j'ai pas envie d'échanger ce fou mais ok
pas si facile à activer les dernières
pièces du coup j'ai peut-être devoir
échanger le foot case marche
ok on va prendre ça comme ça difficile
de le finir en fait donc il repart de
l'autre côté matt laurent 17 en fait
c'est pas trop un souci peut-être cette
histoire il va gagner au pion des six
bien joué de sa part ait épaissi sam
c'était pas très grave
bon c'est peut-être plus grave ça en
fait du coup sa dame rendre de l'autre
côté très très embêtant ça va partir à
était marrante 1 pour la peine mais on
était mieux à un moment donné c'est
juste que là un poil craquer
mais on n'a pas le conventionnel
raté un match je pense je pense faire
caler des 6es mater faillir à tellement
de bons coups la même police doit pas
être évident de choisir j'aurais pas mal
défendu quand même dommage j'aurais pu
faire mieux dans cette partie mais je
trop conventionnel on a été beaucoup
trop conventionnel puisqu'il va rejouer
ou pas est-ce qu'ils aient peur notre
conditionnalité bon parent rejouer du
coup on va jouer un autre adversaire
banque agit nezha ce qui se passe mais
quand même toit un tennis et aura de
foot fric il ya plein de trucs en ce
moment à fellah qui s'est qualifiée hier
je vous fais un petit point faire avec
ces qualifiés compte vers f
c'est un peu le seul truc qui était
intéressant je crois du coup me l'ont
dit les un chardy qui a perduré
bouchardy toute façon il perd tout le
temps fait du coup aller on joue cette
petite variante
je crois que dans le privé nous ici move
à cause kébé ces requins de mémoire on
peut faire peut-être caïds et ça je suis
pas allé au bout d'un match 5 dégage pas
du tout si c'est bon en fait
complètement n'importe quoi mais ok au
moins d'appuis rbo dégage
il faut c'est juste l'objectif d'un coup
en fait un objectif d'un coup se limite
à dire cette phrase en fait face aux
limites c'est ce qu'on peut être limité
à dire ça en fait un très très heureux
de le dire bon ok c'est défendre nos
trucs un don qu'elle adore et du passé
eu 5 et j'ai absolument rien calculer
mais sur quel français 2 juste faire roi
des deux mais je vous double attaque
donc il peut peut-être faire dame f5
d'un match 6 avec un peu la même idée ce
cavalier qui a attaqué je peux par ok à
la machine très bien jouer derrière
ok mais on joue pour le beau jeu
évidemment et le beau jeu je pensais
prendre d'ici et d'aller faire kébé 5
alors pourquoi c'est le beau jeu déjà
parce que j'ai envie que ce soit beau je
dis ce que je veux et deuxièmement je
sais pas il ya ça qui est protégé il ya
voilà ça c'est ça j'avais vu son coût du
coup je vais juste faire ces trois
peut-être et sur dame prendre je sais
pas on va pas faire caillasser 7 direct
on va ramener la tour en d1 l'espèce de
géométrie un peu bizarre géométrie hyper
jolie avec la dame qui défont eu cinq
veaux qui est menaces ma tendance à ses
petits bras franchement ça c'est petit
bram qui on défend et la tour en f1 une
structure quasi blanche passe
complètement dingue
si ferrari on peut faire perpète
paramés nancie ferron quand on faisait
faire d'alger 5 damev si ces dames là
bas ok s'il fait ça
simon et réfléchir c'est parce que j'ai
envie de jouer le beau jeu ultime
bon ok je vous joue le beau jeu ultime
je vais pas prendre la tour en amitié je
vais faire le beau jeu ultime cavaliers
des six puis on prend à jouer le match
angers double m'attend le 7 a cessé de
bouger ultime donc les dames c'est un
fou d un retiens tout un don qu'il va et
vient prendre la tour non c'est grillé
ci lui donne la tour il va faire dame m6
il va sentir d'alger cinq dames e7 qui
arrive du volontairement je laisse à
tour il peut faire petit rock là non il
ne fait pas et je vais faire d'alger 5
je couvre les échecs et je menace matin
le seul donc il peut encore s'en sortir
évidemment en faisant jean roy et fuite
mais je vais aller je vais aller je vais
aller le choper avec du tour f1 c'est
beau jeu ultime cette partie ok tu fais
ça je te fais dame g7
il ya là qui arrive ok tu fais ça je te
fais food boum boum comment tu défends
ta case de 7
le beau jeu ultime le beau jeu ultime
c'est le beau jeu enfin ça vous fait
bien marrer en tout cas fera pas très
réactif dans le chat à ce parti était
marrante prend pas la tour on s'en fiche
on joue le match va mater eux cette boum
le mat
du coup
quels commentaires sur youtube on attend
la nouvelle partie qui arrivent mais cas
directement annulé
du coup on rejoue contre john jose fiche
alors insupportable
ce chien est insupportable alors que vos
questions isolées conclure isolé
du coup je sais pas pourquoi j'ai permis
à faire ce fou j'ai kajima jouais très
mal joué en fait ok que cinq noms qui
font l'essence les gars c'est pas facile
je vais plus jouer des cats en fait si
en plus on a été faibles du coup c'est
de faire un jeu de pièces sur la
lecavalier 6
ce pion des cinq par mon tuteur quelques
décades des trois cavaliers 5 juin
c'était grave ou pas ce qu'il va faire
que je bouge ses pions des tôt ou tard
c'est un petit peu obligatoire
bon ok s'il fait ça je prends avec la
dame de toute façon ça comme ça
mais j'ai envie de faire des cats et de
mettre m'en fous angers 5 une tête ces
cavaliers prend ici plus est
complètement pourri ce que je suis en
train de faire
ce fragment complètement pourri ce que
j'aurais fermé aux pieds je vais être
franc j'ai cinq pour empêcher en fait me
faire chasser la dame et tu peux pas
vraiment chasser ça ok dans qui s'y
réfèrent tour c'est un rapidement pour
chasser le fou
donc il va faire dame prendre des trois
jeux juste échangé des pièces
quel coup tour ici peut-être un peu
désagréable pour moi mais bon
même très désagréable
parce que cette finale en fait j'ai
perdu jean latour sur la deuxième va
être indéfendable ok on va tenter ça on
va prendre je vais fouet 3 ok adams est
mais je sais pas est ce que cette tour
est vraiment si j'ai envie de jouer le
tour c'est un héros est fin prêt pour
essayer de faire un genre d'ami cette
tour c'est un ok là dessus je voulais
faire tour c'est la russie allait venir
là avec saddam ou là ça c'est très
embêtant du coup
ça c'est extrêmement bête en fait que tu
préfères food et 4
pour foncer 3
kim et à metz troyes c'est hyper pénible
mambé 4
je suis patient pouvoir défendre ça
longtemps
on va pas arrêter de défendre au
prochain coup à mascate où ranger 4
maths et surtour des trois en phase i à
tour heures ou autour comme ça mais il y
avait juste aura un math en un ok il
joue pas mal soudain zhou fiche il joue
peut-être mieux que nous
il jouera le mieux que nous ce juke
fiche
il joue même beaucoup mieux que nous
alors j'ai pas su apprendre un nouvel
adversaire
ok c'est quatre cavaliers f6 ici la 14e
avec ses cinq ou six ou pas des cats je
veux laisser 5 assez tôt quand même ok
on est le cas et en c6
il faut s'y prend on va reprendre une
coalition complètement 5 mitric hockey
joué que trois jurys de tenter un truc
marrant à l'erreur prisé des cinq bons
jeux presse c'est bon de moi ça change
un peu alors on va prendre prendre et du
coup je me retrouve à jouer contre
sochaux en d4
ok
quand tu es prendre
mettre le foin cinq sages comprend
akasbi ainsi jamais sifflé gk tu peux
être fou de quatre bras voire au pire
fois aussi soudé 5 un jeu quand même
content qu'il joue et g4 permettra
toujours un peu affaibli hier j'ai
peut-être c'est de faire genre d'armes à
5 tours des huit aux deux prochains
coups tout bêtement
il ya cinq ans on a fixé la case c4 qui
est bien avec saddam forcément grand
chose on à tour séduit pas mais envie
d'enlever quand même la tour de ce truc
là si jamais on pourra faire des six
plus tard ça va être un bon avantage
c'est pour enfin un bon avantage vous
êtes un petit quelque chose pour les
noirs inédit quand même j'imagine tout
cas envie de faire d ici ça permet de
régler tous les problèmes
pas forcément un bon coup qui est
aujourd'hui thomas défendre petit à
petit j'ai envie d'aller l'attaqué petit
à petit la ba fuite
je me sens élevé de manière un peu trop
précautionneuse des derniers coups au
caire marc angers le x e 6 band soit 100
m s'il attaque mes pièces à chaque coup
il se passe pas grand chose
ces menaces sont pas caisse des masses
en un coup quand même pas trop de
profondeur là dedans tu prends un petit
à petit pouvoir remettre le fou en d5
tout est changé et on a l'air d'être
quand même assez bien les tours 2 je
commençais par poussées 4-1 déplacer sa
tour seulement 1,3 ça permettra de
regagner un tempo vrsac et pas même de
regagner un tempo contre fricassée 4 en
fait sur ça que je fous ces quatre en
premier par le train de regagner un
temps tout à l'heure ok donc à ces
quatre là regagner le temps sur la tour
vous êtes vous permet d'avoir encaissé
le pion pas oublier quand on jouera
aussi son regagnera du temps alors pour
le moment ça ça attaque et qui on doit
reculer alors on va aller vers 17 heures
vente ul mans aussi g5 dame prend h3c
campion j'ai envie d'apprendre
même si un pion de l'oeil ça reste quand
même un pion et en plus ça permet
d'approcher la dame du roi est préparée
peut-être des plans à la tour 6 6 tours
agissent pour aller mater en face braga
pas une grande partie 1 mais jugé bien
aimé la d'avoir failli rester ici c'est
après l'avoir fait bien cinq savoir
faire c'est ça un prix d une fois qu'il
a fait trois faits reprises et faire des
cinq pour essayer de jouer contre ça
chercher un autre adversaire alors tall
igor lah allez hop hop l'arrivée de la
mascotte
alors voilà on va prendre des 5 on va
aller vers avec la dame aurait cinq
blindés ça par rapport aux fous ok je
vais cette position qui est pas très
marrante
- il se passe pas grand chose je n'aime
pas trop avec la scandinavia par l de
vendre comme seuls les blancs peuvent
toujours un petit truc et avoir une
position correcte alors ok on va re ok
mais si on robe cavaliers prend russie
suis sûr qu'il y prend 1,6 du coup on a
tous reçu huit importants
on va pas venir reprendre aussi c'est
permettre la double attaque on va venir
cloud et la dame en fait qui est du coup
ils reculent kheddam c7
que faire si j'en ai sky vers des cinq
dates à travers des quatre hommes à
prendre
bekaert en jeu son protégé à 6 si jamais
elle revient vers assises du coup on
empêche à 6 et puis quelqu'un m'avait
pas si mal placé tête pouvoir sauter par
la sphère réussissent mettra le fond f7
un papa très grave tu fous justement
qu'on voulait remettant fc thomas
lemaître direct vois pas tous ces cinq
ou même dans lequel viendront f5
qui est prêt à mettre 7 ou rendez 8 1
qui joue au 5 mai attendait un peu on va
prendre une fois avec le fou ici est-ce
que c'est gravissime ou pas j'en sais
rien
peut-être faire ces cinq sur foudroyé
dame prend 2,5
ok mais si je t'avais prendre b4 je me
sers de ce cavalier qui n'est pas
protégée pour aller lui encaissé un pion
ça c'est une technique c'est une
technique embêtant de sa tactique
embêtante pour thau fliegauf pas
complètement fini c'est encore jouable
mais du coup ça va quand même fait
perdre un petit peu de sa superbe
on va commencer à enfoncer un peu ce cas
valse pions et on risque de faire des
cahiers français trois dames prendre des
quatre en fait avoir deux pions de plus
ah ouais du coup vous bien à lui de
prendre de la dame ici et c'est un peu
forcé les choses forcer les échanges qui
est d'un f2 peut-être pouvoir déplacer
le fou frère qui avait quatre essais de
qualité 3 doit échanger son qu'elle est
de nouveau attaqué le fou un bon
peut-être souvenirs avec le cavalier pas
super envie de le tolérer
mais un look et on va faire bouger six
tours avec deux tours d2 1
du coup bas
allez ici plutôt autour des 2 tours b 2
un clic et des cadres du coup
tiens pas mal quand même ans
il résiste pas mal pour le moment
je veux pas de jeu pas de knock out
comme disent les anglais
j'aime pas trop ce coup de toute façon
juste en fait commencé à pousser mon
pions c'était un bon coup juste comme je
ne trouvais pas quoi faire juste voulu
envoyer mon pions en fait
du coup je me dis ça servira toujours
d'avoir mon cul en c3 sera toujours plus
utile
mais ça le truc avance mais comme ça
plus il avance mieux c'est en fait plus
il peut pas vraiment utiliser les
colonnes ouverte ce qui à tour pranger
de il ya le fou qui vient et du couteau
d'igor en difficulté là enfin cahier de
l'échec à ok bon il ya ça le truc c'est
qu'ici il ya food et 5 ha et jean ferme
pas le cavalier de ce qu'il a à 6,6 à
j'avais pas vu mais bon il était
tellement mal autant aussi qu' il était
tellement mal autant que ça se passait
bien
alors vlad 2000 cren puis
automatiquement c'est un peu un espèce
de vlad allez vous
[Musique]
goût je sais pas pourquoi je vais vous
une deuxième fois mais ça me fait marrer
alors qu'est ce que ça donne cette
position de malades dame b3 qu'elle
allait score du foot coupe des
confédérations pour moi un partout entre
les allemands et les chiliens chien qui
se bat bien reprendre de partout bout
qu'est qui montrent ces élections là
parce complet sûr il y aurait dribble 98
du parti complètement bordélique je ne
comprends rien à ce qui se passe mais je
suis très heureux ban a attaqué la db5
fois fiat j'attaque sociaux on
marquerait qualité 5 attention pour
bloquer je commencerai par leucate
piètre qualité 5 direct qu'ils ont à
faire
tendez faut faire gaffe
donc à se faire enfermer la dame
l'intention les mecs
m'a fallu quelques jours c'était au tour
des 8es keufs
où ça éventuellement
mettez vous êtes un peu trop confiant
pendant qu'ils en bavent eux comme ça va
faire d'amis si on va prendre un truc là
on va prendre une deuxième fois on sait
si ces boues le pion c6 enfin génie ce
pion bout le pion c6 dégage bout la dame
est de retour bometon pions dégage donc
est menacée fusent gagner non changer
les pièces qu'ils échangent
enfin j'ai senti que j'ai senti que ce
pion elle est utile j'ai bien senti la
variante
[Musique]
faire maths de l'escalier voyez choper
avec tours h5 au prochain boom dégage tu
accroches c'est une espèce de groupe
quelque part je pense que rami en
préambule perez comme ça on est obligé
de compter dans la presse de niveau cinq
sens à la prs à fond je comprends que la
dame quand même scandinave dans ta
gueule
il ya d'abord h56 fonds d'ici
ok mais va par ok je le connais mais du
coup je vais les trolls et quart les
bulls damas cinq ça va il s'y attendait
pas qui peut prendre trois pièces pour
la dame ça va être tendu ce qui fait là
il ya un peu obligés qu'ils seraient
allés se faire mater mais bon le truc
qui m'a convaincu de jouer ça c'est que
j'encaisse le pion à deux même à la fin
tempus bout le prévenu faisait froid
dans des cages
c'est un peureux on peut risquer bon ok
tu apprends un de ceux c'est sûr
je n'aime pas voir un poil de mal à
sortir un quart frk et fils
pas très grave si l'apprendre b71
haskell idiot un ska l'idiot pourquoi
j'ai pas vu ça au la 9e glement au nom
l'aveuglément total au nom quel dommage
j'aurais pas du 36 au sacrifice de dames
aulas en deux pièces de moi pareil je
prenne mon billet j'ai vu tous les
autres coûts sauf 16% roi des deux
j'étais complètement hypnotisé aïe aïe
aïe
quelle horreur qu'elle n'importe quoi
comment ces idiots
on va abandonner comme ça on a le temps
de faire une dernière partie aura mais
ça c'était débile après je tentais le
beau jeu à fond aussi un pas du coup on
va leur faire le beau jeu bouger quatre
tentes akl mais quand peu plus h3g
refaire la même le mec va dire c'est
théorique directement il devrait prendre
ici me la bouffe s'en fiche et 1 c'est
son problème
ah c'est ça qu'on attaque de partout on
attaque les pièces tout le temps partout
on attaque tout tout le temps partout on
est absolument inintéressant par les
pions les attaques qu'on ne les mangent
pas attaque pour attac absolument rien à
[ __ ] ok
alors
à jarrie de faire un truc marrant j'en
le prendre et de rentrer dans cette
finale donc je ne pense pas du tout
envie de rendre une finale de base il
dit c'est des gros c'est un gros malade
il se dit c'est un gros malade le mec va
attaquer qu'un malade on rit pense à
nous et là le mec tout d'un coup il va
se retrouver en finale à égalité
matérielle avec un bordel pas croyable
sur l'échiquier éventuellement des
possibilités de [ __ ] la merde ça c'est
pas mal joué j'ai envie d'être méga
takhar alors attendez si on fait pions
francs il fait pions prend on fait f
celle ci fait roi ici et on n'arrive
rien à faire de bons doit faire flasher
4 avec l'idée s'il fait g5 de prendre un
an et quand il fait plus empreinte cas
de faire payer pour h3g du coup d'avoir
la même position s'affoler dans les
pionts doublé angers il allait plus on
roule en h
et ça change énormément de choses parce
que du coup il protégeait plus puant h3
du coup a poussé f7 ici sur échec aux
affaires kf4 a menacé kg 6 ça c'était
complètement con mais ok c'est pas grave
j'aurais mieux fait de faire f 4 comme
veut le faire au début qui allait
prendre h4 ah non accueille trois échecs
ok je suis plus haut niveau
concentration
je n'y suis plus haut niveau
je suis que sur le beau jeu
ok les mecs mais plus non plus c'est le
bordel mais au lieu qu'elle voulait
angers 6 mais du coup on va quand même
la gagner cette partie bouhoula tour et
du coup on n'a pas le temps de faire fou
gecas à tour pranger 4 oui mais non on
recommence essuiera lequel est enfermé
c'est quoi cette partie de dingo eu cinq
échecs bout à y faire rage et cette
cavale yeux 4 ok il se calme marrant
cette partie qui c'est-y pas bon bah je
pense que du coup on va juste aller
gratter le pion va pousser
juste chercher le pion à pousser hockey
a du coup on profite du placement de la
tour pour créer une menace
[Musique]
pas mal joué ça
maintenant je suis en train de faire
n'importe quoi les requêtes avec
lecavalier
tu as vu monter avec le roi bull
ces deux voilà vous me roy on va essayer
de passer en force avec le roi en fait
c'est que je suis en diagonale par
rapport à cette case
on va faire ça comme ça du coup je monte
à fond avec le roi et on va essayer de
faire kelis et 8 e 6 e set
ok là l'idée c'est de reprendre pour me
créer un nouveau pion passer la main
c'est lui qui passe en premier que son
pion war incroyable c'est lui qui passe
en premier que son pion mais j'ai réussi
à l'arrêter et je vais avoir un coup
d'avancé en faisant des mythes d'alger
gagner son pion et en fait on va finir
là-dessus et normalement cette finale à
la gagnante du ce que mon roi est
beaucoup mieux placé que le sein et du
poumon ont réussi à gratter un pion 2 il
va donner suis là comme ça
3 va faire 4 et maintenant la puce est
fantastique du point et le retour du roi
qui va venir finir ce stream sur une
partie assez sympa finalement et on va
finir ça sur une partie assez amusante
finalement contre vlad demi lucre donc
ukrainien est parti assez sympa bon
j'espère que ça vous a plu on se
retrouve jeudi prochain et désolé pour
qu'il prenne internet au début ça c'est
rigolo fermeture d'esprit à bientôt ocha